la salle ultérieure je suis très heureux
de vous retrouver notre invité principal
ce soir c'est jacques vergès
jacques vergès bonsoir bonsoir à l'orge
est ici ce soir pour répondre à la
question que tout le monde se pose entre
mao tsé toung polpot klaus barbie carlos
et milosevic s'était qu'il plus sympa
moi je dirais qu'ils aient tous sympas
mais celui qui m'a le plus impressionné
c'est mao ouais ouais vous savez le tpb
champ public mais dans l'intimité
parfois il aime sa famille il aime son
chien hitler adorait son chien mais ça
s'en vient or paul potts par exemple
c'est vrai qu'il fallait savoir le
prendre mais c'est un mec avec qui on
pouvait bien rigoler puisque les
cogneurs étudiant à paris ouais
lorsqu'il disait des poèmes de rimbaud
il pleurait alors j'ai un copain nous
serons tous les deux nous parlerons de
vous de vos origines de votre enfance de
votre adolescence des causes et des
clients que vous avez défendu jusqu'à
vos débuts sur scène au théâtre de la
madeleine avec une pièce écrite par vous
arrête de pleurer klaus barbie
non ça s'appelle serial plaideur
l'émission s'appelle
[Musique]
ouais
alors jacques vergès rebond soir vous
montez sur scène à 85 ans avec une pièce
de vous adapter par louis charles
sirjacq
intitulé série all plaideur c'est à 18
heures le dimanche et à 21h le lundi
jusqu'au 11 avril le pitch pourquoi
ai-je donc choisi ce métier c'est ça
j'explique que j'ai la passion de
défendre entation qui est souvent mal
comprise parce que l'opinion confond
l'avocat et l'accusé en gb parfois
l'accusé le coupable on essaie de
comprendre comment un mec qui nous
ressemble et arriver à commettre quelque
chose que nous mêmes nous condamnons
vous dit un avocat est là pour défendre
comme un médecin pour soigner
hippocrate disait je ne serai pas la
maladie je soigne un malade - et nous ne
pouvons dire je ne défends pas le crime
ouais je défends l'homme accusé de
l'avoir commis mais vous défendez pas la
pédophilie vous défendez pas le charisme
des fraudes les gens là et quand au
crime c'est le pouvoir politique qui un
jour l'interdît l'ona l'autorisent quand
j'étais avocat stagiaire ya 50 ans je
défends des des jeunes filles des
étudiantes souvent qui s'était fait
avorter on leur disait mademoiselle vous
avez détruit des vies humaines issues de
votre cher au départ c'était interdit à
l'époque maintenant c'est remboursé par
la sécurité sociale
alors c'est pas un plaidoyer à c'est
plutôt une vision générale confie dans
la profession voilà il ya peu de
références à votre vie aux affaires que
vous avez plaidé non parce que si j'ai
fait à des références à une seule la
paire ouais ça devient le débat fait une
seule affaire c'est une approche globale
de la profession au départ c'est une
idée du directeur du théâtre de la
madeleine est venu me voir et il m'a dit
m j'ai vu le film que monsieur barbet
schroeder bout consacre je trouve que
vous avez une présence et que ce que
vous dites est intéressant le théâtre
évolué en ce moment on voit par exemple
monsieur loukine y entretenir le public
pendant une heure et demie sur un texte
de sedin je vous propose d'entretenir le
public pendant une heure et demie
j'aurais texte de vous
pour moi c'était claude inimaginable et
depuis je jouais
j'ai eu du succès vous n'êtes plus à
l'aise sur une scène que dans un
tribunal non sur sûrement sûrement
pourquoi quand je joue devant des
tribunaux devant je suis dont trois
personnes un droit personnes devant qui
je suis au leurs idées des heures fixes
sur la faire
et quand ils m'écoutent c'est cause
toujours tu m'intéresses
tandis que lorsque j'ai 500 personnes il
ya des gens qui viennent avec une idée
préconçue maintenant je vais voir ce que
ce salon va raconter les pires vrai
quand ils sortent ils se disent c'est
plus compliqué que ça mais alors c'est
vrai que votre vie est très étrange à ça
commence déjà avec votre date de
naissance
officiellement vous n'êtes ni le 5 mars
1925 comme votre frère jumeau paul
vergès élu communiste de la réunion au
siam qui s'appelle maintenant la
thaïlande mais en réalité on on sait pas
vous est peut-être née le 20 avril 1924
au laos un an avant vous êtes peut-être
un enfant adultérin dont la naissance a
été déclarée au moment de celle de votre
frère 2 d'abord j'ai aucun souvenir
je suis réduit à écouter ce corps à
corps ou moi j'ai été élevé jusqu'à
maintenant
comme le frère jumeau de mon frère vous
avez trois ans quand le paludisme en
porte votre mère vous l'avez pas connu
en fait j'ai j'ai un vague souvenir j'ai
une silhouette une voix c'est tout ce
que je peux dire
alors vous avez dix ans quant à la
réunion vous surprenez un couple
d'européens stopper ne pousse pousse qui
les balades en donnant un coup de pied
aux malgaches qui tire un couple obèses
et pour le faire arrêter
le type je disais c'est assister à un
âne il fait beau hélas pour un homme
c'est un coup de pied ce choc a été
fondateur pour venter fondateur alors
vous allez 17 ans quand vous rejoignez
les forces françaises libres du général
de gaulle et à la fin de la guerre vous
obtiendrez la médaille de la résistance
avait été extrêmement courageux dans la
bataille de la poche de royan et je
pensais comme gabriele d'annunzio que
sans la france le monde serez seul
et c'est une idée qui me torturaient que
la france disparaissent
les élèves du lycée à la réunion dont
raymond barre qui était mon copain de
classe on a manifesté pour la réunion
rejoindre la france libre et en 42 il
recommande aux france élite qui est
arrivé et là je suis parti avec raymond
barre il dormait déjà en classe à
l'époque donc pas encore encore encore
vous avez 30 ans quand vous inscrivez au
barreau de paris c'est l'époque où vous
rencontrer les futurs chef des khmers
rouges pol potes et khieu samphân vous
admettez avoir participé à leur
politisation non à paris oui oui vous
avez un peu endoctrinés déjà à l'époque
non un peu oui vous avez vu où cela nous
a mené où on ne sait jamais on ne peut
pas prévoir l'avenir
alors vous avez 32 ans quand vous avez
en algérie plaidé pour les combattants
du fln et notamment pour djamila
bouhired accusé d'avoir posé des bombes
dans des dans des lieux publics
et c'est là que vous inaugurez votre
fameuse stratégie de rupture alors la
stratégie de rupture c'est la remise en
cause en fait de la légitimité du
tribunal dira que l'accusation et
l'accusé se réclame de valeurs
différentes
et quand vous avez en face de vous une
terroriste que vous défendez vous dit
non c'est une résistante comme les
résistants français se battait contre
les nazis quoi finalement la stratégie
de rupture c'est quand dans un procès
le comme vous dites l'accusé et le juge
jean des valeurs différentes vous dites
que sur une aile moi je dis que c'est
vous le criminel parce que vous
prétendez maintenir dans ce pays un
autre coloniale que j'estime à juste
sans prendre parti pour l'un pour
l'autre faut concéder que dialogue n'est
pas possible c'est brillant et qu'à ce
moment là
l'accusé sera condamné au maximum mais
ce qu'il faut empêcher ces d'exécution
une exécution réel ne dépend plus du
juge mais du président de la république
c'est ce que vous avez fait un homme
politique et les sorciers bonnes
opinions donc au cours du procès on va
faire appel à l'opie si ce qui s'est
passé avec jamila elle a été condamnée à
mort mais vous la faites gracié et vous
l'épouser
on a fait faiblesse
[Applaudissements]
à ce moment là vous convertissez à
l'islam vous devenez mansour mansour
vergès vous vous installer en algérie et
puis alors là nous y sommes le 7 mars
1977 et alger et vous vous volatilisé en
disant je vais à alicante on vous a plus
jamais revu pendant huit ans oui ça
prouve que je suis discret
vous n'avez jamais voulu dire où vous
étiez seul vos enfants savent la vérité
une vérité qui dit vous saute aux yeux
est que personne ne voit c'est
incroyable ça mais on le saura quand
vous allez me dire un jour oui un jour
je le dirai à vous seulement
merci pour le secoue merci
vous n'avez pas été enlevé par des
extra-terrestres par exemple non non
vous étiez pas qu'elle vit ce nom ici
dans les clodettes de claude françois
voilà et à votre tour en soixante dix
huit vous devenez celui qu'on a surnommé
l'avocat du diable vous défendez klaus
barbie carlos khieu samphân milosevic et
quand on vous demande si vous auriez
défendu ni clair vous dites bien sûr
j'aurais défendu hitler mais ce que je
peux vous dire c'est qu'avec vous hitler
lui après six mois avec sursis c'est
possible vous auriez choisi quoi comme
stratégie de défense il y un bouquin
écrit par un américain comment on
devient hitler c'est quand même avant
c'est y assure la couverture et un petit
gamin un petit bébé qui font ça et on
s'est dit ce petit bébé à la fin n'était
plus là fait une mèche un il envoie des
gens ou des chambres à grains comment ça
c'est fait il y à beaucoup de choses
vous auriez choisi la folie peut-être
non
je ne peux pas savoir
alors vous êtes également l'avocat de
laurent gbagbo faut lui dire à laurent
gbagbo que que c'est un prononçable
léger devant les baies c'est peut-être
pour ça qu'on lui demande de
démissionner oui oui c'est impossible
ouattara c'est facile à dire oui et
dites moi vous qui est l'avocat des
causes désespérées vous défendriez
michèle alliot-marie là
ça serait difficile ouais si vous aviez
besoin d'un avocat vous prendriez qui
aujourd'hui vous kezman
vase après le procès
bettencourt est donc non non écouter il
a critiqué la juge pour son rouge à
lèvres et c'est ça ouais aux apports ne
tape pas un jugement sur ses seins qui
tombent sur ce rouge à lèvres
et corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou